i'm steve ducey i'm dana parino i'm
tyrus and this is the fox news rundown
wednesday march 23 2022 i'm jessica
rosenthal the white house is dealing
with new questions about the business
dealings of the son of the president
hunter biden now that the new york times
has cited the veracity of emails found
on an abandoned laptop when we shut down
stories in this country and try to
portray them as a obsession of the other
side and both sides sometimes play this
game i think that makes lots of average
people go you know what there's so much
partisanship in the media that i don't
know who to believe
i'm dave anthony he was badly injured
reporting in ukraine and today you'll
learn how fox news correspondent
benjamin hall was rescued from the war
zone ben was gravely injured and
moving him was a very difficult decision
that was weighed considerably because of
course
where he was was not a safe environment
for him to remain
and i'm kt mcfarland i've got the final
word on the fox news rundown
[Music]
last week the new york times published
an article about the legal issues the
president's son hunter is dealing with
citing a broad investigation by the
justice department to include possible
violations of foreign lobbying and money
laundering rules as well as whether or
not hunter should have registered as a
foreign agent with the justice
department and then in this article the
new york times mentions the laptop which
fox had reported on before the 2020
election there are serious questions for
joe biden this evening following the
publication of emails allegedly
belonging to his son hunter the
reporting lays out purported emails
between hunter biden and ukrainian
businessman to acknowledge what's
happening on the laptop acknowledges the
other stuff on the laptop the laptop
came under scrutiny before the election
after the new york post reported on its
existence and had come across it through
then president trump's attorney rudy
giuliani it had been left at a repair
shop and not picked up among the items
contained were emails the new york post
said they provided information about
hunter's international business dealings
and the new york times said one email
outlined hunter's vision for his work
with a ukrainian energy company called
verisma even mentioning a need to be
careful to abide by foreign agent rules
but back in 2020 most media outlets
would not touch the story and while many
aren't necessarily now white house
spokeswoman jen saki fended off
questions about it last week i appointed
the department of justice and hunter
biden's representatives i'm a
spokesperson for the united states he
doesn't work for the united states but
despite the new question some of the
focus on the story now is less on what
hunter biden was up to and more on what
the media has been up to my first
reaction was that why wasn't everybody
else now covering this howie kurtz is
the host of media buzz on fox news none
of the other cable networks or broadcast
networks even though the new york times
which is so uh religiously followed
almost every story certainly any story
having to do with anything negative
about donald trump suddenly just silence
crickets and it's almost as if the same
instincts not to jump on this story back
in the closing weeks of the 2020
campaign when the new york post first
reported it uh hadn't gone away even
though we're talking here about
according to the times the president's
son under active federal investigation
for possible tax fraud violations for
possible lobbying violations for
possible money laundering violations now
he may not get indicted it's been three
years no charges have been brought me is
denying wrongdoing but how on what
planet is this not a story
yeah there have since been articles with
very damning headlines uh wall street
journal op-ed as you know said the
failure to report this amounted to an
american accountability crisis a former
congressman from georgia said journalism
died with this story or lack of this
story um is is that
fair is that is it fair to to
characterize the lack of reporting on
this as so dire
well i hope journalism still has a pulse
at least but i understand probably
better than ever why so many people on
the right conservatives republicans feel
like they don't get a fair shake from
the mainstream media because if you go
back it's not just that many news
organizations uh declined to jump on
these hunter biden laptop allegations it
was a big tech it was that twitter
blocked people from sharing the story as
for a time suspending the new york post
account facebook limited the
distribution you had the managing editor
of npr saying we don't want to waste our
time on stories that are not really
stories it was mocked it was minimized
it was played down not by everybody but
for by much of the media it was
dismissed as russian disinformation so
now you know a year and a half later
when you have the new york times saying
yeah you know we've looked into it and
it's all kind of true not the
allegations themselves we don't know
about that but the fact that these
emails are real that there was a laptop
that there is an active uh u.s
attorney's investigation of the
president's son
it still
is being played down to a degree that is
frankly difficult to understand
the washington post as you know has
written a piece explaining why they were
hesitant initially citing russian
interference in the 2016 election
connected to a wikileaks hack of the dnc
when you read that article what did you
make of this explanation was it
sufficient enough to hold back on this
story before an election you know not
really um i certainly understand the
need for caution and when i you know
something like 50
former uh intelligence officials came
out and signed a letter politico and
others covered this saying we think this
is russian disinformation first of all
they didn't have any first-hand
knowledge but you know it was the end of
an election there was obviously a big
attempt on the right to tie hunter biden
to his father and what his father may or
may not have done when joe biden was
vice president so i never thought that
this by itself was going to turn the
election because it was about trump and
kova in the economy and much bigger
picture issues but i think when now it's
like well we didn't do it because of
this and we didn't do it because of that
well many of these organizations still
aren't doing it and i think it smacks of
self-justification the media's
well-known refusal to admit a mistake as
opposed to coming out and saying you
know what we made a mistake we're sorry
but you don't see the media saying that
the new york times acknowledged the
laptop in the middle of an article about
hunter's current legal troubles that
like you said there's a doj
investigation regarding his business
dealings and um the new york times
article begins by talking about a tax
liability hunters paid off and how that
complicates the investigation
does the backdrop of an official
investigation and now this corroboration
of some of these emails
mean it's much easier to talk about
well let's just imagine it was donald
trump jr you think you'd see this great
hesitation among the biggest news
organizations in america to not jump on
the story and i think look that was a
very revealing paragraph hunter biden
concerned about how his tax problems
would look remember he worked for the
ukrainian energy giant burisma he worked
for a chinese energy conglomerate they
weren't hiring him because he knew
anything about energy they were hiring
him because he was the vice president's
son and they thought they could get some
kind of connection to the white house
the fact that he has acknowledged to
associates according to the times taking
out a loan to repay more than one
million dollars in back taxes well you
don't do that if you think you're
innocent you do do that if you think you
might one day be
standing in front of a jury and you want
to say well look i ultimately belatedly
did the right thing that paragraph alone
i think would be worthy of media
coverage and i don't say this because
you know i want to prop this story up or
give it more attention that it's worth
but it's certainly worth more attention
than it's getting from most of the media
right now
in terms of the content you just you
just referenced some of it you know we
know at least like one of the emails on
the laptop had to do with burisma hunter
biden on the board of that company in
ukraine that energy company it sounds
like he had introduced one of the
executives there to his father who was
the vice president at the time and this
executive according to the new york post
had written an email asking hunter how
he could use his influence
and as we later now know that same
company that was being investigated by
ukraine's top prosecutor
you know biden had said that he needed
to be fired if ukraine wanted certain
aid money when you hear these kinds of
things these sort of international
dealings and the connections then to the
vice president at the time who is now
the president obviously
how important is it to know more to find
more of those emails to delve into this
story deeper
well first of all vice president biden's
insistence that the ukrainian prosecutor
be fired was quite public he bragged
about it because the obama
administration thought that there was a
lot of corruption in ukraine nobody's
ever proven that joe biden got a dime
out of any of this but you know here's
the larger picture hunter biden is a sad
character he was for many years a drug
addict he's written a book about this
he's acknowledged it uh what he did even
though it is fairly common among
relatives of members of congress
executive branch officials and other
movers and shakers here in d.c
what's the pedal influence you know
he was hired because he had the last
name biden and these companies thought
that would provide an in that doesn't
mean he committed a criminal offense but
when you add all this up but you're
saying what is the news value here we're
talking about the son of the president
of the united states clearly it has a
lot more news value than many
organizations at the time or even now
seem willing to acknowledge and that
lends credence to those who believe
fairly unfairly that
joe biden as a democratic president gets
treated differently for his family
problems than did donald trump or other
past republican presidents
now i know we have many more
intelligence officials in our country
than 51 but 51 of them did as you noted
signed that letter saying you know this
story about this laptop has all the
hallmarks of russian disinformation
what role do you think that letter
played and how much do you think
that kind of thing undermines trust um
in the intelligence community or or in
the people reporting on the intelligence
community for that matter yeah that
that's a very fair question i remember
thinking at the time a lot of them
probably former democrats and that they
didn't know has all the hallmarks is not
evidence you're speculating now the
russians are certainly capable of it we
learned that in 2016. but that doesn't
mean in this instance it was
disinformation in fact we now know
thanks to the times is reporting and and
that by others that this laptop was real
that hunter apparently left it at this
delaware repair shop that it has emails
on it that certainly raised questions so
um i'm just always wary when experts say
there are stories experts say this that
the other thing is true because
sometimes they're just wrong
howie um if the gp wins in midterms this
fall we've already heard talk of what
they would like to do in terms of
investigations and panels and inquiries
would you anticipate that if republicans
take the house and or senate that we
will hear and see more about this story
and about this laptop and about the the
business dealings of hunter biden
absolutely positively no question about
it and look when uh one party controls
at least one house
they often use that the democrats have
done this as well uh to investigate the
party controlling the white house and if
it's somebody usually somebody who may
be the president appointed or is close
to the president when it's a family
member though does raise certain
sensitivities um you can be sure that
not only will we hear a lot more that
there will be subpoenas uh you know
we're seeing the flip side of that with
the democratic
controlled january 6 committee a very
important topic to investigate but
republicans can complain it's being done
in a partisan way so
it's very likely
after these midterms that republicans
will control at least one chamber of
commerce uh and i think that uh the
hearings won't be far behind
howie finally i just want your sort of
broad take on trust in the media and how
polarized it's it's gotten we've even
seen since then
um the the articles that do discuss the
laptop have have said you know the far
right was very concerned with this
laptop the far right was you know was
was focused on this and i'm just
wondering
when we characterize you know
media in those terms far right and far
left media um is that part of what
undermines the trust or what's sort of
your broad take takeaway from this story
in in in connection to the public's
trust in the media
what the mainstream media tried to do
and what twitter in particular tried to
do was to paint this as just some sort
of obsession of right-wing media what
the new york times story clearly
demonstrates and i give the times credit
by the way it was it was a well-reported
story with a lot of new details uh why
it came out now i'm not really clear
was to show that this isn't just some
conservative fantasy that there's a real
story here the same thing had came up
with the wuhan lab leak theory and then
the wall street journal and other
reporting led to people to say well you
know it could be a possibility that when
we shut down stories in this country and
try to portray them as a obsession of
the other side and both sides sometimes
play this game i think that makes lots
of average people go you know what
there's so much partisanship in the
media that i don't know who to believe
or i'm just going to watch
or read the outlets
that agree with me and i don't think
that's healthy for america
howie kurtz thank you so much for your
time
happy to be with you
this is kt mcfarland with your fox news
commentary coming up
russia has been bombarding ukraine for
almost a month now president vladimir
zelinski in an appeal for help told
italy's parliament
the air bombs keep killing ukrainian
people
and some cities like mariupol are fully
destroyed many civilians are among the
casualties so are journalists last week
a fox news crew came under attack in a
village outside the capitol keefe fox
cameraman pierre jakshevsky was killed
so was journalist sasha kushniovo who
was working as a consultant for fox
correspondent benjamin hall was badly
injured now being treated at a u.s
military hospital in germany
unfortunately as i think you all know
we're all too familiar with these kinds
of injuries
and we've built up
an expertise in how to treat
the kinds of injuries that mr hall had
pentagon spokesman john kirby told fox
and friends it was our honor to be able
to help and again we we just want to see
him get home safe and sound and get back
to his family but it wasn't the us
military that rescued benjamin hall it
was a group called save our allies we
have this great partnership with fox and
we've all been through a lot together
sarah varado is a co-founder of save our
allies and so
many of the fox members knew that our
team was on the ground in ukraine
and when this horrific attack happened
we were contacted to see if we could
assess the situation with benji and
potentially locate pierre and sasha and
so our team they took what would
typically be a multi-month process of
just planning alone and within hours
they engaged a multinational effort
that ultimately
not only did they get and were able to
extract
benjamin from behind enemy lines in
ukraine but then they were able to rely
on handing him off to the u.s military
who got into that final leg of safety
from poland to germany where he's
currently being treated it was really
wonderful to see everybody rowing in the
same direction for this goal of doing
the right thing so how do you do that
how how do you coordinate such a thing
you just said behind enemy lines you
have the war going on you have the
shelling continuing you have russians
attacking ukrainians fighting back how
how does someone coordinate and get to
someone like benjamin hall and and this
site where pierre and sasha were killed
i have had the easiest and cushiest
role in all of this in the safety of my
own home just helping by making phone
calls and being on the computer but the
guys that i am so blessed to serve
alongside for this mission that save our
allies they are veterans of the special
operations and intelligence communities
and they are skilled in precision
extraction hostile environments on five
continents i mean these are the this is
the a team and so it's like kind of a
movie really it it is it is and it's you
know our ground commander let we call
him sea spray that's obviously a moniker
we
we are so grateful to know that men like
him exist who are willing to use their
skills and expertise in a very
thoughtful way
in coordination with this amazing
network of multinational efforts our own
u.s government our own u.s military to
put this together and
be able to be the life-saving difference
in the case of benji but these guys that
i'm so blessed to serve with i can't say
it enough they embody the send me spirit
of going in and and being the difference
makers against evil it's really
inspirational and and and you guys got a
medical team there right you know yes
sir for the transportation i mean to get
him out you are you had a medical team
there
helping to i assume stabilize and and
and and make his trip more comfortable
ben was gravely injured and moving him
was a very difficult decision that was
weighed considerably because of course
where he was was not a safe environment
for him to remain but at the same time
there was incredible risk moving him
due to where his injuries are located
and the severity of those injuries and
so this team at save our allies our
ground team they made a very thoughtful
decision and we have a lot of
medical personnel former special
operations doctors and different
personnel including also battlefield
trauma surgeons who volunteered left
their cushy homes and lives in suburban
america and said send me and they went
and they served on yet another front
line this time as an all-volunteer force
and so it's amazing one of those
gentlemen was the one who
really
hand walked this process with benji and
stayed in frequent communication with
the military doctors who would
ultimately receive him on the usg side
and so made sure all of that was just
lockstep and that made the life-saving
difference and you had to work with the
polish military correctly because he's
got to get out of ukraine
absolutely so
really when i say this was a
multinational effort that can't be
stressed enough this was an example of a
public-private partnership which of
course we love between save our allies
and the u.s government and then our
allies and friends in the ukrainian and
polish special operations community
their militaries their leaders it was
something that everybody came together
we did not let red tape slow it down
everybody was committed to doing the
right thing so he
then gets into a u.s military medical
center
how quickly does this all occur
from the time that you guys can get to
him to the time that he's given over to
the u.s military for care it was
probably about 24 hours that our team
was with ben and then was able to hand
him over and off to the 82nd airborne
and some of america's best fighting
forces in poland that then they were
able to spring into action and get him
to germany in which he's receiving
incredible care at the military the u.s
military hospital there
sarah varado's organization went to
ukraine to help americans stuck in the
country and it has a lot of experience
getting people out of a war zone in a
short time
created out of the chaos in afghanistan
last year when u.s troops pulled out and
the taliban took control
saber allies was formed back in august
2021
when afghanistan collapsed and it was
me and i'm the wife and caregiver of a
catastrophically wounded veteran who
suffered life-changing injuries in
afghanistan along with three of my
friends who are incredible veterans from
the special operations intelligence
communities
and together we decided we wanted to
ensure we'd keep this moral obligation
we had not only to our own american
citizens that were trapped when we knew
the us government was not coming to get
them out but also our combat
interpreters and so our efforts in
afghanistan led to us evacuating 17 000
people
i did not personally do any rescuing i
was here on my computer and on my phone
i understand all hours i was working on
a 22-7 schedule as i like to call it but
there was a 10-man ground team and a lot
of those members are now
engaged again for us in ukraine
volunteering to
do the right thing and so our effort
with many partners on the ground and
great coordination and support that we
received from so many different
avenues
allowed us to evacuate americans
combat interpreters and other vulnerable
populations and that work still
continues one of my great friends nick
palmiciano came back yesterday he spent
the last 48 days in the middle east
still trying to do the right thing for
people that are trapped in afghanistan
that have been left behind
sarah mentioned her husband michael who
was badly wounded in afghanistan in 2010
her caring for him led to her
volunteering for others with a group
called the independence fund which
provides a wide range of physical and
mental health services for injured
veterans it's given 2 600 of them what
are called track chairs which is kind of
like a wheelchair meets a tank
all-weather all-terrain vehicle now
she's not just a volunteer anymore sarah
varado is now that fund's ceo
you know when my husband we met when we
were teenagers in high school and when
he went to war he thought he was going
to war and coming home
or going to war and not coming home and
he was okay and had peace with either
option oh i see it sounds it you know it
sounds very silly to say this now
because of my work in this community but
i don't think we ever considered a
middle ground in which he would come
home just so critically injured and
we've existed his 12th alive day is next
month and the state of north carolina
recognizes as a holiday here because my
husband has endured so much he's been
through 120 surgeries
post-afghanistan he's had very
significant and rapid declines the last
couple of years did you say a hundred
did you say i'm sorry did you say
120 surgeries
yes sir oh my oh
ah and so it goes up to him and you that
that's very difficult
but you know what's important to know is
that there there have been some very low
times there have been times where i did
not think that he would make it through
the day or where the doctors thought we
were back on imminent death status or
that things were very dire again and i
will tell you we've had incredible
support system and at the top of that
list is i have to she'll hate that i'm
i'm recognizing her this way but is
jennifer griffin she's always been one
of the first people busting through
those hospital doors to quietly sit at
my husband's bedside and she's been
wonderful for my children for me and so
has so much of our fox family and we
really do feel part of that fox family
and so as i know that the hall family is
now looking at a long journey and what
comes next i know that they are also
going to be just embraced by fox and the
resources there to make sure
that this is as comfortable
and seamless as possible given
just how gravely ben was injured and
what is to come
both emotionally and physically for this
family i've talked to his wife i mean
she's a fighter she's a she's a mother
they've got three little girls and i've
i've been
blessed to be in pretty frequent contact
with her and all i keep thinking is that
you know they're not a military family
right did not expect this to happen and
so i am so grateful and i know i joined
the overwhelming majority of americans
to say i am so grateful for those that
are going into harm's way to share
real-time information and the actual
news
and benji has
done an incredible service to his
community to this country and i know
that that family will be honored for it
and they're going to need a lot of love
over this journey and i know they're
going to receive it how does someone
help with the independence fund and how
does someone help with save our allies
well
to visit the independence fund please
www.independencefund.org
and for save our allies
www.savehourallies.org so please check
them out they're both great missions
a lot of synergy for people that are
serving still in one way or the other
who want to do the right thing for the
global community
well we thank you for everything that
you did to
help
and rescue benjamin hall our
correspondent who is a long recovery
ahead of him and for the work you did
also to help extract uh the remains for
pierre jaczewski and everything you did
also
uh we really appreciate everything
sarah varado co-founder save our allies
thank you so much for joining us thank
you for having me
[Music]
did you hear the news now you can with
instant updates from fox news for amazon
alexa just say alexa play news from fox
in fox news it's the latest when you
need it on demand from fox news and
amazon alexa rate and review the fox
news rundown on apple podcasts or
wherever you listen
it's time for your fox news commentary
kt mcfarland
what's on your mind like many people
i've been mesmerized by images coming
out of ukraine miles of russian convoys
russian missiles deliberately targeting
schools and hospitals russian troops
shooting women children and old people
whose only crime was queuing up for
bread
a brave articulate ukrainian hero
president leading his army and fellow
countrymen to defend against the cruel
russian invaders i know how i want this
to end but can someone tell me how this
is likely to end
america has just fought and lost two
wars in part because for 20 years we
never had clear or realistic objectives
it is ukraine's opinion that matters of
course not ours but it's worth thinking
this through now at a certain point
things could escalate presenting the u.s
and nato with some difficult decisions
we would have to make very very quickly
what are our goals in the russia-ukraine
war is there anything the u.s can do now
to help achieve them how can we separate
what we might want from what is possible
is our goal putin's utter defeat and
withdrawal
putin could not survive politically at
home if he brings the troops home in
humiliation before that happens he will
escalate to weapons of mass destruction
including chemical and even tactical
nuclear weapons
is our goal regime change in moscow a
pals coup orchestrated by putin's inner
circle well that's unlikely given his
paranoia control of everyone around him
putin's goal is to do whatever it takes
to bring ukraine to heal
would we be willing to sit on the
sidelines while putin levels ukraine
like he did chechia 15 years ago and
bomb kiev to smithereens like he did
grozny
if ukraine becomes a killing field it
would be a stain on the soul of the
world
is our goal a stalemate followed by a
negotiated solution where neither side
gets everything it wants but both sides
get enough they can live with what would
such an agreement look like zielinski
now says nato membership is off the
table for ukraine and even hinted that
the fate of the two eastern provinces
might be negotiable
those were putin's main demands before
the invasion will there be enough for
putin now
can he spin that to his own people as a
victory and bring his troops home
or will he demand all of eastern ukraine
no matter what putin agrees to now he'll
be back he will rebuild his military and
return for the rest of ukraine in a few
years time
but a few years would also give ukraine
a unique opportunity to rely on western
investment to rebuild
strengthen its economic and political
ties to europe and north america and
wean itself off russian energy what is
our role in all this president biden so
far has shied away from doing anything
that might draw the us into the conflict
or give russia an excuse to escalate
biden wants a diplomatic solution but
history shows the most effective
diplomacy is backed up by a strong
economy a strong military and solid
alliances the best weapon the united
states has to stop putin and help
ukraine and the other countries putin
might be eyeing down the road isn't
military it's economic
unleash the u.s energy industry if biden
is willing to end or delay his war on
fossil fuels the u.s could produce more
oil and natural gas that would drive the
energy prices back down to where they
were under president trump
that would cut putin's export revenues
in half he wouldn't be able to afford a
costly occupation or further invasions
biden's sanctions may punish putin for
invading ukraine and that's all well and
good
but taking away his piggy bank would
prevent him from going to war again i'm
kt mcfarland i was president trump's
first deputy national security adviser
and i'm a board member of the american
conservative union i'm also the author
of revolution trump washington and we
the people
you've been listening to the fox news
rundown
stay up to date by subscribing to this
podcast at
foxnewspodcasts.com and for up to the
minute news go to foxnews.com
from the fox news podcasts network
subscribe and listen to the trey gowdy
podcast former federal prosecutor and
four-term u.s congressman from south
carolina brings you a one-of-a-kind
podcast subscribe and listen now by
going to foxnewspodcasts.com
love fox news click the subscribe button
to get more of the news and opinion you
trust and click the fox news rundown
playlist for the latest episodes